Dark chocolate.
White chocolate.
Biscuits.
Hot chocolate.
Pralines, bonbons, chocolate
cake, chocolate bars...
From sweets to cosmetics,
cocoa is everywhere
and 60-70% of it comes
from just two countries,
Ivory Coast and Ghana.
When you get to farmer households,
you'll find that some may never
even have tasted chocolate.
Cocoa farmers largely live
under the poverty line of $1.25 a day.
They really can't even
afford the finished product.
The $100 billion chocolate industry
is plagued by child labor
and has historically been a leading cause
of deforestation in both
West African nations
that receive a pittance
for selling their beans.
The two countries alone represent less
than 6% of the global value,
including the taxes that the
country is taking from exports.
The farmer is probably
getting less than 2%.
But soon, even these small percentages
may be lost completely,
as the main importer
of West African beans,
the European Union, gears up to ban cocoa
with a harmful impact on the
environment and human rights.
If there was a legislation there
that prevented West Africans
from selling their cocoa,
there would really be an issue
for the economies, for the
farmers, for the governments.
And so, that has added to, I think,
what was initially more of a moral issue
and made it very much an economic issue.
And these attempts by developed nations
to force a cleanup of cocoa supply chain,
while potentially hurting the livelihoods
of West African farmers,
might not even achieve
their desired goals.
Cocoa and chocolate world
are stuck in colonialism,
making the poor nations poorer
and the rich nations richer.
And that has not changed at all.
Cocoa, a tree crop native
to Central and South America,
was introduced to Africa
over a hundred years ago.
Colonial powers like France
and Britain compelled
some of their colonies in Africa
to cultivate crops that
they don't want to cultivate
because of the ecological costs.
After independence these countries
just keep on producing this raw material
which they export to Europe and America.
It's almost a classic
colonial division of labor.
Cocoa has remained intertwined
with the economies of
Ghana and Ivory Coast,
their fortunes often rising and falling
with the price of the crop.
After Ivory Coast, or Côte d'Ivoire,
gained independence in 1960,
its first president and
the political elites
were cocoa growers who
encouraged production.
In Côte d'Ivoire, in
the 1950s, 1960s, '70s,
some of the richest men
were actually cocoa farmers.
And there was a speech by
the first president saying
if you want to be rich, plant cocoa.
But the global price of cocoa continued
to reduce in the early '60s
to the point that in 1965,
some cocoa planters in Ghana judged
that it makes no sense for
them to harvest their cocoa.
The first president of
Ghana, Kwame Nkrumah,
had seen his country's economic reliance
on a crop with such
volatile prices as perilous.
He stopped funding new cocoa farms
and then tried to diversify.
Also tried to create a situation
whereby Ghana would be
processing its cocoa.
Unfortunately, that
didn't come to fruition
because of the 1966 coup against him.
The volatility of cocoa prices continued
to destabilize the Ghanaian currency.
And after a second coup in the '80s,
the government of Ghana made
a pledge to its cocoa farmers
to never let the farmgate -
the price it would pay
farmers for their cocoa -
slide below a certain threshold.
So there are two prices.
One is fixed by the government
and one is determined by the markets.
The price of cocoa on
the international markets
is essentially affected
by supply and demand,
with most of the supply
coming from West Africa
and most of the demand coming from
the EU and also North America.
Cocoa is the main export revenue
for Ivory Coast and the
third biggest for Ghana.
About 60% of this exported cocoa
ends up in the European Union,
mainly in the form of unprocessed beans.
While we talk about price of cocoa,
the world is changing.
Supply and demand is probably
not the market of tomorrow,
because we have another element,
which is sustainability.
So we see in Europe,
there are even right now
regulation proposals to ban
cocoa linked to deforestation.
Cocoa's connection
to deforestation dates back decades,
a direct link to the traditional method
of cultivation used in
Ivory Coast and Ghana
called slash and burn.
Farmers just cut down these trees
and you burn the entire land.
Then you plant, harvest, and
then move to another forest,
plant, harvest.
So after slash and burn planting,
you tend to harvest quickly
and you tend to use less labor.
The problem with this is
that the amount of forest is finite.
So in Côte d'Ivoire there's
almost complete deforestation.
There's no new land for
cocoa farmers to move to.
To try and reduce this deforestation,
Ivory Coast and Ghana
have been forcing farmers
to replant cocoa on the same land,
even as the soil's nutrients get depleted.
But replanting on the same spot
requires more workers and
more input to grow the crop,
shrinking farmers' already tight margins.
You now have to weed.
You now have to buy
fertilizers, pesticides.
Second, third replanting,
you need to increase
your use of fertilizers.
So if your cost of
production keeps going up
and you have no control over the price,
then you have to look
for a way of deflating
these extra costs,
which is one of the causes
of increases in child labor
and child trafficking.
This is a way of deflating cost of labor.
Cocoa is not an easy crop to grow
and it competes for labor with
other activities in the area,
like small scale gold mining,
which is often illegal
and known locally in Ghana as galamsey.
Cocoa farmers often run farms as a family,
which is why cocoa poverty
is such a big issue
because a farmer would support a family
of six or eight people.
Usually it's small-scale farmers.
So they plant in the farm
and then they come home
and dry the beans before packaging them
and selling it to, in Ghana's case,
the Cocoa Board through licensed buyers.
The problem with this is
that most of the benefits,
it's mainly in the
manufactured aspect of it,
while most of the costs - for
example, ecological costs -
is mainly in the raw
material aspect of it.
Most cocoa beans are processed
once they reach their final destination
in the factories of
chocolate-making companies.
A study of the chocolate
value chain by Oxfam showed
that the grinding and
production of chocolate amounts
to more than 25% of the price of a bar.
While in the '70s, when cocoa
prices hit record highs,
the farmers' share was nearly 50%,
today it's down to around 6%,
and that's likely to include
taxes and fees of middlemen.
Today there's more middlemen.
They are basically
squeezing out the profit
for cocoa farmers.
That's one way of explaining it.
Another way would be to say
that there's more consolidation
of market power in the
chocolate production,
as well as the retail
part of the value chain.
One other way of doing it
is to look at the cost of production.
So the cost of producing cocoa now
and the cost of producing
cocoa in the 1960s and 1970s,
it's not even close.
A new cocoa is demanded in the market.
Cocoa produced sustainably.
And we need to ensure that anyone
that feels that sustainability
is just about deforestation,
it's not the case.
Deforestation or any human rights abuse
seen in the cocoa sector are
the consequence of poverty.
And we need to tackle the root cause.
To tackle farmer poverty,
the government of Ivory Coast and Ghana
introduced an initiative in 2019
called a Living Income
Differential, or LID,
which requires confectionary
companies to pay a premium
of 400 US dollars on each
tonne of cocoa they buy.
This money is then incorporated
into the farmgate price
to bring a bigger slice
of the bar to the farmer.
In the first year of the LID,
the farmgate price in both
countries increased nearly 20%.
The World Cocoa Foundation
that brings together
companies representing 80%
of the global cocoa market
has welcomed the change.
This new tool is really effective
in getting farmers out of poverty.
We think that it is
not possible to sustain
the cocoa industry at the
detriment of the farmers.
So it's not a nice thing to do, actually,
it is the right thing to do
if we want to sustain the cocoa industry
for the benefits of all the
members of the supply chain.
If you're a cocoa farmer,
your income increases by 20%.
You are now happy, and yes,
there's more money in cocoa.
So if you are thinking of leaving cocoa,
there's no point leaving now.
The inevitable outcome of this would be
an increase in outputs.
So an increase in outputs would mean
a further reduction in market price.
And in fact, in the last cocoa season,
within Ghana's case, it had
a record production actually.
So there was actually oversupply.
And so, that also gave
less negotiation room
in terms of fixing pricing
with their main buyers.
So this is actually good for cocoa buyers,
for multinationals who want more cocoa.
But I think it will be bad
for Côte d'Ivoire and
Ghana in the long run.
In an effort to clean up the supply chain,
governments have also been
trying to create mechanisms
to ensure the traceability of beans
to the farm where they were grown.
Ultimately, that would be the first step.
If we can trace the cocoa,
that would help make
for a cleaner cocoa industry
and cleaner cocoa supply chain
where all the stakeholders
along that supply chain
can be held responsible.
So that will be really the quickest fix,
to put it that way, even
though it's taken a while,
but the bigger opportunity really
is to improve industrialization
and manufacturing.
That would be a way of breaking the
neo-colonial patterns of trade.
So to break that chain would be
to process the raw materials
in Africa before you export.
African economies have been locked
in similar trading patterns
with other commodities,
like crude oil or cotton;
exporting raw materials for a low cost
and then importing finished goods.
But a growing taste for chocolate
and a rising middle class
provides an opportunity
to keep more of the value
of cocoa within Africa.
And so, in Ghana's capital, Accra,
an industry of artisanal
chocolate makers has taken root.
It's a work of passion.
I've fallen so much in love
with cocoa and chocolate.
When I started, it was very
difficult to get information
on cocoa processing and
chocolate production.
I had to go to the U.K. to
learn how to use the chocolate.
However, in the last six years,
there's a growing small industry.
I think it's important
that now the current administration
is pushing the eating of
chocolate and cocoa products.
Bioko Treats is a boutique chocolate brand
that caters to emerging local appetites,
but it hasn't always been a smooth ride.
Access to affordable funding,
you know, it's just about non-existent.
So the company cannot grow
maybe as quickly as it should.
To have an impact
on the wider chocolate industry,
change needs to happen on a larger scale.
Hendrik Reimers is the founder
of Ghana-based chocolate maker, Fairafric.
With no bank willing to fund
what was perceived as a risky project,
his company went online
to crowdfund a factory.
It was built in less than half a year
and has the capacity to
produce 4 million bars
of chocolate a month.
Currently, the advantages
of producing chocolate
in West Africa are not all that many,
rather to the contrary, we do face a lot
of infrastructure challenges.
Where we are producing here
we had to bring our own internet,
we have to supply our own water,
own electricity most of the time,
we depend on our own
wastewater management.
So technically speaking,
it will be much easier to
produce chocolate in Europe
where all that infrastructure
is already set up.
The choice of producing in rural Ghana
is one to make a statement
and to show the world
that we can make world
class chocolate here
where the cocoa grows as well.
Fairafric is the only large-scale factory
in Ghana producing chocolate for export,
but the company's ambition is
to grow the domestic industry
so it can compete in the
international market.
We set up a chocolaterie school
where we train local talents
in the art of praline making.
We exported the first
shipment of pralines,
which the students have made
after a year of training.
And one of the trainers said
this is the same quality
that we have made in Belgium.
So that was one of the proudest
moments I've ever seen,
you know, people seeing
that they're getting
that kind of comparison, having made
like the same quality that is produced
in Switzerland and in
Belgium here in rural Ghana.
I think that's a significant game-changer.
The company aims to source everything
within the African continent.
And the reasonably long
shelf-life of commercial chocolate
has allowed Fairafric to
overcome supply chain issues.
But despite the appeal of this model,
none of the multinational
companies have followed suit.
The real reason that we see very,
very little infrastructure
in terms of adding value to resources
are the tariff kind of policies of Europe
that have always said you
can bring in your commodities
without any duties paid,
but if you've made something out of it -
be it semi-finished products,
like cocoa mass or cocoa butter,
or even chocolate finished products -
then duties have applied.
So you've immediately been
at a cost disadvantage
and it forced all the value addition
to commodities towards or into Europe.
And only since around like 20 years,
that has been changed
and the playing field was leveled.
If you consider this very
issue of local processing,
it is reflective of the set of regulation
that has been put in place.
Depending on the way the government
is adjusting the regulation,
maybe tomorrow's picture
would be different.
Government, for example, is pushing
to having national investors in it,
but is considering to reach out first
to the private sector
and try to reach the win-win agreement.
I think politically in the spirit
of African self-sufficiency,
Africa rising,
the idea is one that anyone
can really easily embrace,
but the practice of it is one
that's difficult to implement.
The more components there
are in your products,
the more standards you have to meet.
The fact that you can
just export raw beans
and get your dollars,
the quickness and ease
with which you can do that,
is really hard to overlook.
Because of the export revenue component,
it means that there's always
going to be a trade-off.
It's not just a matter of
transforming the beans,
but getting it to a point
where you can export and earn.
And alongside economic incentives
and regulations, the role of consumers
in shifting the whole industry
shouldn't be underestimated,
as history shows.
Consumers, as far back as a hundred years,
have forced Cadbury to
source their cocoa from Ghana
where slavery was already abolished.
The consumer is not used to the idea
of 'Made in Africa' yet,
or 'Made in 'Ghana'.
If you tell someone 'Made in Germany',
that really rings a bell, that resonates
and it has a certain message.
And although it kind
of looks simple to say,
look, we are adding a lot of value,
we create meaningful, well-paid jobs
producing chocolate here,
you only have that split second
when a consumer decides to buy chocolate.
It's been a major challenge,
but we've done a lot in
terms of explaining that.
Almost everyone loves chocolate,
but it's important to
ensure that it's cleaner,
less heavy on the environment,
but also fairer on the people
that actually toil the land.